- Hi, my name is Alan
Gerber and I'm the director
of the Institution for
Social and Policy Studies,
the sponsor of tonight's event.
Tonight we're gonna be
having a panel discussion,
excuse me, a few speakers
followed by a question
and answer period.
The topic for tonight's session
is what did the voters do,
and why did they do it?
And so for this event,
we've gathered four experts
on political behavior,
American political behavior,
to put what happened on election day
and after election day into perspective
and shed some light on
the science of the study
and understanding of voter behavior.
Tonight we're gonna have a
question and answer period
and here are some of the logistics
associated with that and
the rest of the event.
Please send questions to the panelists
using the question and answer button
at the bottom of the Zoom screen.
The questions ideally
should be relatively short,
so please try not to write a paragraph
if you think you can
write maybe a sentence
or a sentence and a half.
It'll be a lot easier for us
to process those questions.
The event is being recorded.
If you need technical assistance
please email isps@yale.edu,
so that's isps@yale.edu.
And here's the format for tonight's event.
Following my introductory,
welcoming remarks
and biographical details
about tonight's panelists,
each of the panelists will
talk for about seven minutes,
sharing a few of their critical
insights, their key insights
about the election with you.
And then we're gonna have a
question and answer period.
So you can start sending
your questions along
whenever you have them.
And they'll be gathered up
and I'll ask them of the panelists
after their remarks have concluded.
That part of the session
will go about 30 minutes,
I would imagine.
Great, so tonight let me now
begin welcoming the panelists
in order of their appearance.
They are going to be speaking
in alphabetical order.
We're gonna begin with Alex Coppock.
Alex is an assistant professor
of political science at Yale,
and a resident faculty fellow
at the Institution of
Social and Policy Studies
and Center For The Study
of American Politics.
And Alex's research lies
in the study of political persuasion
and its implications for the malleability
of public opinion in the
context of elections.
He's an expert on the design
and analysis of randomized experiments
and he won the Best Software
Award for DeclareDesign
and that was awarded by the
American Political Science Association
Political Methodology Section in 2019.
Alex is working on two books now,
one on research design
and one on persuasion.
If you're interested,
you can check out some
of Alex's scholarship.
One of his recent papers
in science advances
is on the subject he'll be
talking about in his remarks
that's a paper called "The small effects
of political advertising are
small regardless of context,
message, sender, or receiver,
evidence from 59 real time
randomized experiments."
So you can check that out
and other of Alex's works.
Next, we'll be hearing from Josh Kalla.
Josh is also an assistant professor
of political science at Yale.
He's also a professor in
the Department of Statistics
and Data Science.
He's a resident fellow at the Institution
for Social and Policy Studies.
Josh studies political
persuasion, prejudice reduction,
and decision making among
voters and political elites,
primarily through the
use of field experiments.
Kalla was awarded the
Leamer-Rosenthal Prize
for Open Social Science,
and his work has also been
awarded the Cialdini prize
by the Society for Personality
and Social Psychology,
an award that recognizes the publication
that best explicates social
psychological phenomena,
principally through the use
of field research methods.
Josh's scholarship has been published
in numerous academic journals.
If you're interested in
reading more check out
"Reducing exclusionary attitudes
through interpersonal conversation,"
published in a recent issue
of the American Political Science Review.
Welcome, Josh.
Next, we'll hear from Mike Podhorzer.
Mike is assistant to the president
for strategic research at the AFL-CIO.
He's a leading political
strategist and analyst
for over 30 decades and has
led the federation strategy
to create permanent, year-round
mobilization capacity
to elect worker-friendly
candidates, advocates for issues,
and demand greater accountability
from elected officials
independent from political
party structures.
He established Working America,
a community partner
organization that has grown
to three million non-union
members nationwide,
reflecting a focus on
all working families,
whether or not they are covered
by collective bargaining.
Podhorzer led the federation's work
on voter protection efforts
and voter mobilization strategy
during the most recent election.
He is a recognized leader in his field
and he was also a pioneer
in data-driven politics
and is admired by all
those who are interested
in the science of voter behavior.
And then we'll be hearing from.
Oh I should also say, he was
one of the founding chairs
of the Analyst's Institute, one
of the leading organizations
for bringing science to campaign activity.
And then we'll be hearing
from Lynn Vavreck.
Lynn is the Marvin Hoffenberg
professor of American politics
and public policy at UCLA.
She was PI of the 2020
election project Nationscape,
the largest study of
presidential elections
ever fielded in the United States.
The project has been interviewing
more than 6,000 people a week
and will complete 500,000 interviews
before the inauguration in 2021.
Are you still in the field?
Great, that's really good to hear,
'cause this was one of those elections
where you were wondering if it would end.
And so it's great that
you're still in the field.
Did you decide that before the election?
- Through inauguration day.
- That's pressing, pression, very good.
Lynn was a recipient of
the Andrew Carnegie prize,
one of the kind of big fellowship awards
in the social sciences.
And I don't know if it
helped fund the research
that I just described or
not, but it probably funded
some important studies
that you've conducted.
Lynn is the author of
five books including,
"Identity Crisis: The 2016
Presidential Campaign,"
and the "Battle for the
Meaning of America,"
described as the most ominous
book on the 2016 election.
Lynn is also a contributing
columnist to The Upshot
at the New York Times.
Lynn is a leading scholar
of American politics
and American elections and it's wonderful
that she's here joining us
from Los Angeles tonight.
With that, why don't we just
turn it over to our panelists.
They will speak without
interruption in between their talks.
Alex, Josh, Mike, and Lynn in that order.
And then we'll open it up
for question and answer.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you Alan.
Thanks everyone for joining tonight.
The paper that Alan referenced is
"The small effects of political
advertising are small."
And it has two smalls
in the title which was,
like the editor of the journal was like,
"Are you sure there's not a typo here?"
I'm like, "No, no, no.
The small effects of political
advertising are indeed small
regardless of all of
the things in the title,
so context, and the
kind of person you are,
and the time of the elections.
That's what that paper finds.
And I'd love to talk more about that,
but I actually prepared a
different topic for you.
It's about the pre-election polls
and the difference between
the pre-election polls
and what actually occurred.
And so the source of biases in the polls
are something that we need
to shake out as a community.
We need to figure out why it is
we're unable to seem to
estimate with as much accuracy
as we would like what the
vote margins are gonna be.
And I wanna talk about one source of bias
that I actually don't think is a problem.
And it comes up a lot, which is this idea
that some people, when we
get them in the interview,
we ask them who they're gonna vote for
and they are embarrassed,
or they're worried
that they will experience
shame if they admit
who they're gonna vote for.
And this happened in
particular with respect,
or the idea is that it
happened in particular
with respect to Trump voters.
So because Donald Trump
is associated with racist
and sexist views, people
who are Trump supporters
were worried that if
they admitted in a survey
that they are Trump supporters,
that they would themselves
be seen as racist or sexist.
So that's an example of sensitivity bias.
So if a question is sensitive
it's because I think
that if I say my true answer
that I will experience
some cost, perhaps in
embarrassment or other things.
And sensitivity bias is a real thing.
So, in authoritarian
regimes we can demonstrate
that people over report support
for authoritarian regimes
because, perhaps rightly,
they expect bad consequences
if it is found out that they
don't support the regime.
So we know that through these techniques
that indirectly estimate
support for the regime,
or in this case, indirectly estimate
support for Donald Trump.
So in the 2016 cycle, I did a thing
called a list experiment.
And this list experiment
is an indirect method
of estimating support for a candidate
that doesn't require a person
to directly admit their true beliefs,
but they can let us know in another way.
And I'm gonna share my
screen to show you an example
of what that experiment looked like.
So what we did is we split a
sample of survey respondents
into two groups, a control
group and a treatment group.
And the control group was
asked the question on the left.
"So please tell me how many
of these following things
you would do.
We don't want to know
which of them you would do,
just how many."
So the list is:
"If it were up for a vote, I would vote
to raise the minimum wage.
If it up for a vote,
I would vote to repeal
the Affordable Care Act.
If it were up for a vote, I
would vote ban assault weapons."
So we don't say which of
those things you would do,
you just say how many.
So perhaps your answer is two.
If you were assigned
to the treatment group,
you saw those same three
things, plus a fourth item.
"If the 2016 presidential
election were being held today
and the candidates were Clinton and Trump,
I would vote for Trump."
And so if you then say, two.
I don't know whether you
would vote for Donald Trump
or you would do one of these other things.
So this is a way in which we would protect
survey respondent's identity.
If we then take the average difference
between the treatment and control group
that forms an estimate of the fraction
who support Donald Trump.
Okay, so cat's outta
the bag, when I did this
I found no difference, none,
between the list experiment estimate
and the direct question estimate.
So this indirect thing,
which made it so that people
didn't have to directly admit
and be embarrassed about their
support for Donald Trump,
it didn't change our estimate
of the support for Donald Trump.
So, if we look on the left
we have strong Democrats,
the small dot is the
direct-question estimate,
the big whiskers, that's the effect
from the list experiment.
And we can see that since the
confidence levels overlapped,
it's approximately the same answer.
And that pattern persists
for all seven flavors
of party identification that we measured
in this experiment.
So, establish in the
2016, that I don't think
that shy Trump supporters,
the sensitivity bias
with respect to the
presidential vote twist question
is a major source of bias.
I didn't do it again in 2020,
but there were other clues
that sensitivity bias
is not a major group factor in
explaining the polling miss.
So, on the left-hand side, so this facet,
the presidential facet, this
is not a graphic that I made,
this is made by Thomas Wood,
who's just an unbelievable
data visualizer.
I'm in awe of what he's
able to do so quickly.
He was making graphs like
this on election night.
In each state we're seeing
the pre-election polls
minus the actual vote
totals in each state.
And we see that over here,
we are getting really bad,
we're missing by 15 points
in Biden's direction.
What we can see for sensitivity bias
is that we missed the
same states for Senate
that we miss for the presidential.
So, if people are uncomfortable,
you'd have to believe that
they're also uncomfortable
admitting their support for Susan Collins,
as they are uncomfortable
admitting their support for Trump.
And we don't think that that's the case.
So what we think instead
it's not once we get them in the survey
are they lying to us,
the problem is before then.
The problem is we're not
reaching the right people.
And so, with response rates what they are
we're having to do all
the statistical wizardry
to try and re-weight the
polls in order to get
a more accurate picture
of what's gonna happen on election day.
And for two election cycles in a row,
our re-weighting strategy
has not been successful.
Now, I'm in the privileged position
of not having to actually
do that hard work myself,
so I'm throwing stones.
But I don't think it's
because of sensitivity bias,
I think that it's due to
selection into the sample.
So that's all I have for you.
I think Josh, you're up next.
- Thank you so much Alex
for opening that up.
And thank you all for joining us,
taking time out of your
evening to come listen to us
talk about the world of politics.
So, today I wanna talk
about what I think matters
in presidential campaigns and
how this sometimes differs
from what some analysts,
what some talking heads say
and support what other
analysts and talking heads say.
I wanna kinda stake a
claim in this argument
as to what matters in
presidential campaigns.
And to illustrate the next step in this,
I just wanna use the example of Texas.
Everything that I'm going
to say you could apply
in different states, you could
apply to different candidates
and presidential races,
but Texas is a nice example
coming outta the 2020 election.
And one of the big questions
I have been asked is
why did Joe Biden lose ground
with Latinos in south Texas
and more broadly, why
did Joe Biden lose Texas?
And coming outta the race you see
two very competing explanations,
and the TexasMonthly has done a nice job
interviewing folks on the ground
and trying to get their
interpretation of the race.
And reading kinda the popular
press version of the election
you see two competing arguments.
One is exemplified nicely by Chuck Rocha,
who used to work for Senator Sanders
and now runs an organization tryin'
to organize Latino voters.
And what Chuck says is
it's really a matter of campaign tactics.
He's quoted as saying that
the reason why Joe Biden
lost in Texas is, quote,
"nobody was knockin' on people's doors
and letting them know why
they should vote for Biden."
And that's kind of one very
common argument you see
throughout the presidential election,
it's all about tactics.
If Biden had done more of X,
or if Trump had done more of X,
they would have won
rather than someone else.
On the other side you see an argument
where it's not about tactics,
it's very much one about messaging.
And this I think is explained
nicely by Joacim Hernandez,
who used to run a local
Republican organization in Texas.
And here, he's quoted as
saying, "I think Trump
kind of hit it right on
the head for people here
with the 'drain the swamp'
message, because the Valley
has been riddled by corruption.
People here have seen how year after year,
at least one elected
Democratic official locally
has been indicted for
bribery or corruption.
I also think the riots and
calls to defund the police
turned off a lot of people who
are normally maybe moderate
or conservative Democrats
and come from law enforcement families
who were just appalled
by that kind of message."
So this is very much a
debate of campaign tactics,
campaign contact, versus messaging.
And we as social scientists
actually know a lot
about this debate and
many people on this panel
have written a lot of
research on this debate.
So I'm actually citing
most of the research
from other panelists.
And hopefully I get them right,
and hopefully they agree
with my interpretation.
But, Professor Gerber has
done really path-breaking work
on what we know about the
effect of campaign tactics
on the ability to increase voter turnout.
And if you're interested in this topic,
he has a fantastic book
with Professor Green called,
"Get Out the Vote," which goes through
all of the social science,
all of the evidence that we know
on ways to increase voter turnout.
And what they find in this book is that,
in high-salience elections,
such as presidential races,
for every 1,000 conversations
that a campaign has
they're able to generate
about seven additional votes.
And in practice, a
campaign needs to knock on
about three doors in order
to have one conversation.
So we can do the
back-of-the-envelope math,
and we can ask ourselves,
if Joe Biden just knocked
on more doors in Texas
would he have been able to win?
And to kinda put the cart
before the horse answer,
the answer is no.
So if you go through the math,
in order to have won Texas
through mobilization,
through increasing turnout,
Joe Biden would have needed to
mobilize 630,000 additional votes.
And this would have required
around 4.4 million conversations,
which would have required
knocking on around 13.2 million doors,
and unfortunately for the Biden campaign
there are only about 7.5
million eligible voters in Texas
who did not vote in 2020.
So there just aren't
enough of these voters
for additional campaign contact,
additional campaign conversations
to really make a meaningful difference
in overturning this
particular election result.
And we can think about a different way
campaigns might be effective,
and that is through persuasion.
And this is something I've
written a little bit about.
And in my research,
we find that for every 1,000
conversations a campaign has,
they're able to persuade
around six additional votes.
They're able to generate
about six additional
votes through persuasion.
And in order to have won
Texas through persuasion,
the Biden campaign
would have needed to get
320,000 Trump voters to
instead become Biden voters.
So we can again go through
that back-of-the-envelope math
and see that this would have required
around 1.9 million conversations,
5.8 million door knocks,
and unfortunately, there
were only about 5.9 million
Trump voters in Texas.
And we can also think about
the work that professors
Coppock and Vavreck, along
with Professor Hill have done
on the small effects of
political advertising
are small regardless of context message,
sender or receiver.
Because of these small persuasive effects
there just often aren't enough voters
to have a meaningful impact
when it comes to presidential races.
So, I think from what we know about
the science of campaign outreach,
it's just that more campaign outreach
often isn't sufficient to
change election results
in presidential elections in swing states.
I used Texas as an example,
but we could apply this
back-of-the-envelope math to other states
and come up with a very
similar conclusion.
There's just limited
effect of this outreach
and not large enough
effects to meaningful change
these presidential election results.
I do wanna just like raise a
very important caveat which is,
if you do this kind of
work, if you volunteer,
if you work for an organization
who does this kind of work,
you're efforts still can
make a very big difference
because some elections are really close
and the evidence that we have is that
there are larger effects
in primaries, local races,
and ballot measures.
So if you do this kind of volunteer work,
double down in those types
of primaries, local races,
and ballot measures, 'cause that's where
the back-of-the-envelope
math is much more favorable.
So what does matter in
presidential campaigns
if it's not additional campaign contact,
additional campaign outreach?
And here I want to point to
a really influential book
that Professor Vavreck wrote
called "The Message Matters."
And Professor Vavreck isn't
paying me to say this.
This is not a paid endorsement,
but this is a really influential book,
and if you're interested
in understanding presidential campaigns,
I highly recommend checkin' it out.
And the title does a nice
job capturing what matters.
It's presidential, it's in the messaging.
And Professor Vavreck
lays out some predictions
as to what kind of messaging
campaigns ought to be using.
And she talks about two situations,
one where the economy is good,
one where the economy is bad.
And when the economy is good,
we should expect the incumbent
should focus his or her
campaign message on the economy,
championing the fact
that the economy is good
and thus you should
reelect this candidate.
And for the challenger,
they obviously don't want
to talk about the economy,
because that helps the incumbent.
Instead, they should focus
their campaign message
on some other popular issue
where they're more popular
than the incumbent.
The incumbent is stuck
in an unpopular position
and this other issue is
or can be made important.
And when the economy is bad
we would expect the opposite prediction.
And Professor Vavreck has
a really nice conclusion
where she says, "Candidates who violate
these prescriptions, these
predictions lose elections."
And by inverse, when they
follow these prescriptions
they win elections.
So it's really about, not these
individual campaign tactics,
but these broader meta-narrative
points about the messaging.
About are you focusing on the economy,
if the economy's good
and you're incumbent.
Or are you focusing on
some other popular issue,
if you can't talk about the economy.
And this idea of messaging
really needs to be
talked more about and taken seriously.
And I think really helps us
understand presidential election results.
So thank you all so much
and I look forward to
the rest of the panel.
- Thank you.
I have to say that really feel
a little bit out of place,
as I come to this from a
somewhat different perspective,
in being very much about
the practice of politics.
And the odd thing in listening
to the last two speakers
is that I may actually believe
that campaigns generally even matter less.
Even though that's what I've spent like,
as Alan said, 300 decades doing.
And I really wanted to take on
a lot of what was just
said, but instead I'll do
what I was gonna start out doing.
Which is sort of do a sort of
broader sweep on all of this.
So, imagine that United
States were 100 people.
And on November 8th, 2016,
51 of them voted for Hillary Clinton,
49 of them voted for Donald Trump.
You then had a quarter
million people dead of COVID,
30 million people were unemployed,
racial justice movement,
his impeachment, all of that stuff.
You end up outspending Trump
by 3:2 with $14 billion,
and one X moves from the Republican side
to the Democratic side.
That's it, that's what happened
over the last four years.
That is it, right.
You're in a room with 100 people
and what happened was one person
crossed the other side of the room,
after spending $14 billion.
So, how'd that happen?
We saw unprecedented political engagement.
Four years, as I said, of
like insane dislocation.
Uncertainty that none of
us had really experienced
in our lifetimes.
And almost no change in
our political choices.
Which has to lead to kind
of epistemological angst.
Like we don't know what the
heck is happening in this world.
So, just to run through that.
To really get a sense, this is,
the level of increase in civic engagement
is like hasn't happened.
It just hasn't happened.
The last two cycles, if
you look on the right,
it's things like people
coming home from World War II
that saw the same kind
of increase in turnout.
Trump is like a political noise machine.
He makes every election the Superbowl.
And what that means is that
just like the Superbowl
people who don't even watch
a game during the season
show up for the party.
And that's what happened in '18
and that's what happened now.
It's like incredible engagement.
He's the most unpopular
president in a way that again,
you just have to really see
stuff like this to comprehend.
The only president who never had a month
where he was above the water.
There hasn't been a
period since he announced
that more people wanted him
to be president than didn't.
That his approval ratings,
despite all this turmoil,
stayed with a standard deviation,
that other than Eisenhower
is unbelievable, completely out of whack.
And the structure of the
race never changed from 2016.
It's like the people were
organized around Trump,
that was it.
People who had voted for
one of the two in '16,
not many of them moved and the
movement was always toward,
a little bit of movement
net towards the Democrats
because there was a Lincoln
Project, no Roosevelt Project.
The Johnson, Stein voters
there wasn't a poll
where the Democratic
margin was less than 10.
2018 midterm voters, 20 points.
So like that should have fueled our sense
that the people were
moving away from Trump
to a greater extent, which lead
to these kinda crazy things.
You know, with 90% chance he's
gonna win 347 electoral votes
more than twice as many
popular vote margin.
I'm just putting the numbers up here,
so like I'm shut, like have some semblance
I'm not making this up.
Basic thought experiment.
And the first row's just
like the 2016 election.
This pretty much, for three
of the folks on the panel,
who like read me writing
about this ahead of time,
this isn't like post talk.
So basically you have the 2016
voters were 2.2 for Clinton.
People who voted in
2018, were 22 points for
the House Democrats, which
meant people who came back
from the '16, were five points Democratic,
and overall it was a 7.4 point.
Everything like completely
consistent with the story
all of us wanted to know.
Which is people were done with Trump
and moving away, all that.
Which made the polls seem more reasonable.
So I did a thing where I did it two ways.
One is assume that all the people
who voted in 2016 really
didn't change their mind.
And if they didn't change their mind
and the people who showed
up in 2018 didn't show up,
then the 2020 election
should be 4.5 spread,
which is what it actually is.
Or the people who showed up
then were 5.1 for Democrats,
were actually reflective of
Clinton voters, 2016 voters,
and it should have been seven points.
It should actually be a little bit less
if you do fancier math,
but that's basically
the order of magnitude.
So the polls were like,
which were above that,
like we're living in a
world that couldn't exist.
But that was sort of what was goin' on.
I thought ahead of time
six was gonna be it.
But that's sort of what was real.
But that fed our
willingness to believe polls
that were telling us something
very, very different.
Because we've just seen Democrats
win these big victories in 2018.
We saw polling that we liked and all that.
But I would argue that
polling can't be fixed at all
when Trump is on the ballot,
because there are no shy Trump voters.
In fact, if you get in a room with one
that seems like a silly concept.
MAGA hats the whole thing.
Who are they?
But they don't like to take polls.
And not because necessarily they think
they're a Democratic plot,
but that's just not who they are.
So imagine, Dave the
backhoe driver in Michigan,
who's never thought that there was
a candidate like Trump to vote for before
and never showed up.
When he decides, "Wow,
Trump's the real deal,
I'm gonna go out and vote."
He doesn't realize that he also
has to get on a YouGov panel
or a Lucid panel, or something like that
so the rest of us know that
he's part of the electorate
and is gonna turn out in 2020.
Which is why the polls
were right on in 2018,
not on at all in 2020.
But that's a lot of what's going on.
And you can't fix that,
because in 2016 people wanted to believe,
it was this white, non-college thing.
But I don't have enough time to say
why that's really pernicious
and wrong and bad.
But it's not right, it didn't work.
It's really just people who
like Trump do not like polls.
That correlation it's
not a demographic thing,
it's just who they are and all that.
And the second thing though,
which is in some ways more important,
is that the polls failed to do that,
but we also failed to
just use common sense.
For people that really
are engaged in politics
and believed it.
Because it's like we've
become sort of a society
that wants to know what the weather is
and checks our app
instead of going outside
and seeing what's goin' on.
And that's what the polling was.
We were just like looking at these stats
without like actually going out
and looking at what was
happening in the world.
So again, have the receipts,
over the summer just thought,
well this is not right.
Looked at two things.
One was voter registration.
White non-college off the chart.
Democratic base groups depressed.
A clear signal what was coming.
Then you get to early vote.
Big campaign to get Democratic
base voters to vote early.
No campaign to get white, non-college.
White, non-college among
non-voters is keeping pace
or exceeding Democratic base groups,
who had $200 million thrown
at them to go vote by mail.
All of which is saying, polls
that are saying the opposite
can't possibly be right.
And so that basically
leaves you in a place where
you just can't depend on the polls.
And I think I'm outta
time, but to wrap up,
if you really step back
and were like clicking too
much on FiveThirtyEight
or reading all these, all of this stuff
was narrating noise in the polls.
We were getting stories about
seniors doing this and that,
doing this and all of that,
to just to account for statistical noise
and for these errors.
If as a practitioner
on November 9th, 2016,
I knew Michigan, Pennsylvania,
Wisconsin, Arizona
were gonna be key, but
Nevada was or wasn't,
didn't see Georgia,
didn't need a single poll
for the next four years.
And if I had them, I
thought Florida was in play.
I thought North Carolina was in play.
All of these things that were illusions.
So I think that's time.
And I'll stop there.
- All right.
I think I am next.
And I'm also gonna share
some visuals with you.
It is a pleasure to be
here, virtually in New Haven
with all of these people from
whom I have learned so much
over my career.
And I'm gonna just talk briefly
about how I think about
what happened in 2020.
So, I like to think about
presidential elections
as having two components.
The big things, and these are
the things that always matter
every presidential election,
they affect the vote choice.
These are things like
party identification,
the state of the nation's economy.
Josh has told you a little
bit about my messaging work
surrounding the economy.
I wanna talk about that a little more.
So that's the first set.
And the second set are the things
that I call the swing things.
So things that happen
maybe in one election,
but not in another election.
This might who the candidates are.
It might the messaging that
they choose to focus on.
It might be whether there's
a global pandemic happening,
whether there's a global financial crisis.
So, things that you can't count on
happening every single year.
So big things and swing things.
And we're gonna talk about
a few things in each set
in the next couple of minutes.
So the first big thing I
mentioned is party identification.
And the way that I want everyone
to think about party identification
is that is strong and stable.
Strong because most people in the country,
most people who turn
up to vote in elections
have a party identification
with one of the two
major American political parties.
Maybe 10%, somewhere around
10% of the electorate,
probably less than that,
will consider themselves
to be truly independent of party,
and not even say they
lean when you push them.
So almost everyone has
a party identification.
And then conditional on
having one of those party IDs,
people pretty much vote for the candidate
that is in their party.
So for example, in 2020
about 86% of people
who call themselves Republicans
voted for Donald Trump.
90% of people who call
themselves Democrats,
oh sorry, that should
say voted for Joe Biden,
not Hillary Clinton.
So the robust effect of party
identification on vote choice.
So those numbers are really big.
They're close to 90%, they are like that
every presidential election,
plus or minus two or three points.
That's a lotta people
doing what we can predict
they're gonna do, a long time in advance.
People's party
identifications rarely change.
So, if you were a Republican last time,
you're probably still
a Republican this time.
So that means that the number of people
who can swing elections is a small set,
but it's an important and pivotal set.
And so we wanna think about that.
Okay, a second big factor
that matters every year
is the state of the nation's economy.
And as Josh mentioned earlier,
I have spent a lot of time
thinking about how important this is
in every presidential election
and how it sets the stage
for presidential campaigns.
It isn't the play, but
it's the stage dressing.
It tells you whether we're
watching a comedy or a drama.
So what I'm showing you here
is just a little bit of evidence
about how robust the effect
of the nation's economy is
on presidential election outcomes.
On the horizontal axis
here, I'm showing you change
in the nation's economy,
GDP growth let's call it.
In the first six months
of an election year,
January to June of every election year,
the year markers here are
plotting symbols indicating
the presidential election.
On the Y axis, I'm showing you
the incumbent party's share
of the two-party vote in these elections.
And I've drawn a line here,
that's sort of the line of best fit
through these plotting symbols.
And you can see that it slopes upward.
What does that tell us?
It tells us that as GDP is increasing
in the six months of an election year,
so growth is positive,
incumbent parties do better.
When growth is negative,
incumbent parties do worse.
So, incumbent parties in
growing economies typically win
and incumbent parties in shrinking
economies typically lose.
And I've highlighted here 2020 for you.
If you're curious, right here is 2016,
almost exactly on the prediction line.
Here's 2020, and you can see Trump
is over-performing his economy,
but it is the worst economy,
in terms of GDP growth,
that we've seen since The New Deal.
So, out here with 1980 and
Jimmy Carter's reelection.
But 2020 is kind of unique.
And I wanna show you a
little bit about why.
The state of nation's economy
is a little complicated
because of the stimulus payments.
So, on the left side here is
the graph I just showed you.
This is GDP growth.
But on the right-hand side,
same Y axis, same vertical axis,
but now I'm showing you growth rate
of real disposable income
per capita, January to June.
You see the same trend.
RDI goes up, people have
more money in their pockets,
it's better for the incumbent.
But here's 2020, it is now
the best-performing RDI
economic election since The New Deal.
So 2020 presents this national context,
this economic context to people,
where the nation's economy
is shrinking and quickly,
and in a very sort of scary way,
but in terms of how much
money people have available
they have more than in any previous
presidential election year.
So this is a little bit
of a unique situation.
If you look at 1980, here's
the other bad growth year
and RDI is also shrinking.
Here's global financial crisis.
So it's unusual to have an
election that is the worst
and the best on two different
economic indicators.
So that's gonna maybe complicate
the role of the economy in 2020,
but maybe not, let's see.
So what kind of a swing,
now let's move to things that swing,
what kind of a swing did we have in 2020?
So I'm showing you here states
and Obama's two-party vote margin in 2012,
on the horizontal axis.
And then in 2016 on the vertical axis.
So he's the same guy running
in each one of these elections.
And you can see that these
states are performing differently
in '12 than in 2016.
Some states he's doing better in 2016,
Texas, Arizona, California.
I'm sorry, he's not the
same, it's Clinton again.
I really have a problem identifying
which election she's running in.
So 2016, this is Obama
in '12 to Clinton in '16.
She's over-performing him
in California, Arizona,
and Texas, and under-performing
in Ohio and Iowa.
So this is sort of a jagged pattern here.
Some states better some states worse.
Let's look at the swing from '16 to '20.
And you can see that this
looks a little different.
Some of these states were still counting
when I made this figure.
So they have tightened
up closer to the line.
But you can see almost all the states
have swung toward Joe Biden in 2020.
And almost by the same amount.
So this is what we would
call more of a uniform swing.
There is something about
2020 in relation to 2016,
that is pushing everybody in the country
in the same direction.
And when you compare the
difference in '12 to '16,
there's not that same uniform swing here.
Some states are going more Democratic,
some are going more Republican.
So we wanna think about, what
is driving this uniform swing
and is it something about the campaign,
is it something about the election year?
Prime candidate COVID?
Identity politics?
All of these things are
potential candidates.
So, I'll tell you just quickly
about some of the work that I've done
to try to figure out
what's driving the shifts.
Turnout is a big part of this story.
So let's just stipulate
that that's a big component
and Michael just told
you a little bit about
how that might work.
I'm interested in the
switching, the persuasion
that Josh was talking about
and how much of that we can
see happening from '16 to '20.
So partisans come home,
that's the first story.
It is not surprising,
that's the stable feature,
party identification.
If you were a Democrat who
voted for Donald Trump in 2016,
you were more likely to come home
to the Democratic Party in 2020.
There isn't a lot of
cross-party switching.
Independents are gonna
switch more to Joe Biden
than they are switching to Donald Trump.
So I'm using now my
massive data collection
that Alan told you about in the beginning.
So if you were an independent in 2016,
in 2020 you are more likely to
switch your vote to Joe Biden
than you are to switch to Donald Trump.
So independents are moving toward Biden.
But I wanna just say
something about COVID.
COVID is a player here and it is I think,
the feature of 2020 that is most going to
define the outcome of this
election, close as it was,
as Michael just said.
So, 87% of Americans say they
are very or somewhat concerned
with the Coronavirus.
And that number, concern is declining,
but it isn't declining a lot.
That's a pretty robust
number across the entire
several months of the
crisis, of the pandemic.
And concern about COVID is associated
with switching
disproportionately to Joe Biden.
And let me just show you one table
that will illustrate that.
What I'm showing you here
are Trump voters from 2016.
So these are people who in my survey
tell me they voted for
Donald Trump in 2016.
And I'm showing you across the top here
the distribution of COVID
concern for those people.
So 46% of Trump 2016 voters
say, I'm very concerned
about Coronavirus, 34%
say I'm somewhat concerned
about Coronavirus, that's a lot of people
if you add those two number together.
Those people are switching in
2020 to vote for Joe Biden.
And I'm showing you here,
did they stay with Trump
or did they switch to Biden,
And you can see 15% of
these 46% of Trump voters
who are very concerned,
are switching to Biden,
and 6% of the 34% who
are somewhat concerned.
So that's a lot of people who
are worried about the virus
switching to Biden.
The same is not true for
Clinton voters in '16.
Most of them are also
concerned about Coronavirus,
but the big switching to
Trump is happening here
where nobody, nobody lives here.
Very few Clinton voters are not concerned,
or not at all concerned about Coronavirus.
And those are the people
who are switching to Trump.
There's not a lot of switching
among people who are worried.
And so I have done this
kind of switching analysis
for a number of things.
For racial attitudes, there's
some small effects there.
For worried about losing
your job and the economy,
there are some small effects there.
But these COVID and
Coronavirus concern numbers
are the biggest in terms of the things
that are pushing people to switch.
And so I will end there.
And now I think we're gonna
open it up for some questions.
- Great, thank you very
much Alex, thanks Josh,
thank you Mike, and thanks Lynn.
So there are buncha questions,
but maybe it would be good,
I think there was enough,
I don't think disagreement,
but I think there were some
areas of little arguments
that didn't exactly match
up among the panelists.
So I just wanted to hear
if there are any questions
that panelists wanna, or
any issues, or subjects
that the panelists just wanna start with,
given the very stimulating presentations
by each of the four panelists.
- Can I ask Michael a question?
- [Alan] You sure can.
- Can you just tell us the
difference in the first rows
of your 2016 voters.
What's the difference
between those first two rows?
- You mean from the two scenarios?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I missed, one had the
two-point Dem advantage,
the other had the five-point, yeah.
- Yeah, so basically the edge cases
are that the people who go-
- Oh, I see.
- Came back and didn't change at all.
They still voted 2.2 add
that to the 22 points
the 2018 voters were and
you got 144 million people
voting at 4.5% Democratic.
Or they all come back and
vote like they did in 2018-
- I gotcha.
- [Mike] And then you get to seven points.
- I gotcha, I gotcha, okay.
- So, there are a few
questions about polling
and the accuracy of polling.
And so I wanted just to ask the panelists
to comment on that.
I think Alex alluded to the fact
that there's a lot of weighting
going on in the polling
and alluded to response rate issues.
I don't know that everyone
knows what the response rates
are on polls.
One thing I say sometimes to folks is
do you remember if you had a very good
high school statistics
course you learned about
the properties of a random
sample from a large population
and how if you pull a
relatively small random sample
from a large population,
you're still able to get
very accurate estimates of
the underlying properties
of that large population.
And so, when you hear about
the errors in the polls
reported in the media, that
has absolutely nothing to do
with that model you learned
as a high school student.
You're not getting a random
sample from a population.
It's really you're getting
a lot of weighting going on
to a relatively small number of responses.
But if you could explain
Alex what you think
about the response rates and the weighting
and what role you think that played
in the issues with the
polling in this election.
- So, as I said, I'm not a polling expert.
I understand it on this level.
The people who respond
to polls are different
from the electorate.
We have two problems.
We don't know who they want to vote for
and we don't know whether
they're going to vote.
So then we ask people, "Who
are you gonna vote for?
And are you going to turn out to vote."
And then we need to say,
"You're a kind of person
of this class.
We know that there are
so many of that class
in the population.
And so then, we're going
to multiply your answer
by the weight that we think you exist
in the overall population.
So we're gonna up-weight
you by the proportion
of people who are like
you in the population."
And so we've got this problem.
Do we know the kinds of
people that there are?
And I think Mike's point,
which is just really interesting here.
What's the problem is that
there's a type that we don't have
which is the Trump voter
who doesn't take polls.
And that person, first
of all, we don't know
how many of them there are.
So it's difficult to obtain the amount
by which we need to multiply the thing.
And the ones that we are
able to get on the phone,
or able to get to take the YouGov panel,
might be unlike their brethren who won't.
And so we don't know what to re-weight by.
So Mike also alluded to this idea
that we need to weight by education.
That was the big explanation
for the 2016 polling failure
is that we were weighting
by demographic variables
like age and gender.
What we needed to be weighting by was
how educated the person, basically
we weren't getting enough
people who had low levels of education.
So, gonna take the people who
had low levels of education,
raise their weights up in the survey
and then we would get the right answer.
Well, we did that this round
and we did not get the right answer.
So, I think Mike's almost
like tautologically right,
evidently we didn't get
the Trump supporters.
And this is the big problem to solve.
How do we fix that problem?
- Lynn, you've had a lot
of experience in polling.
I'd love to hear from
Mike, but before we do that
I'd like to hear from you.
What kind of response rates
are we getting these day for polling?
'Cause that gives us a sense
of what the role of weighting is.
- Well, they're super low.
They're super low.
A traditional, random,
digit-dial telephone poll,
which I don't know if
anybody does that anymore,
but those kinds of not
sampling off a list.
So you're just tryin' to reach
people in some random way.
Those are gonna be in
the low single digits.
If you're list-based sampling
you can be a little higher than that.
But nobody is getting
50%, no one's getting 30%.
Those are miracle numbers.
And so everybody is compensating.
And I'll just say two other things.
One is you really want
to, people are weighting
to 2016 vote, which we
know the outcome of 2016.
And so these pollsters
are adjusting the sample
so that it gives them the outcome of 2016.
And they're still wrong in 2020.
So this isn't just that we're
not finding Trump voters.
We're finding Republicans,
we're finding Republicans
who voted for Trump,
we're making the sample give us
exactly what the outcome was in 2016,
and it's still off by a lot.
And so I think a huge culprit here is
getting the set of people right,
who are eventually gonna
turnout in the election.
That has to be a huge part
of how wrong 2020 looks.
And that would explain, I can't remember,
Alex put up the graph about
how the Senate races are off,
like the presidential races.
If we've got the composition
of the electorate in 2020 wrong
because more Republicans turned out
than anybody thought ever
would, or something like this,
then the polls are gonna
be off in both those case.
So that's a leading culprit.
- Great.
I slightly misspoke when I
was talking about weighting,
I think the problem with the
low response rate I think is
even if you get the observable
demographics correct
it may be that the individuals
with those demographics
are not representative of the demographic
you're trying to weight everything up to.
Mike or Josh, do you wanna comment
on this idea there are a
lot of questions about,
about the polling.
And I just wanna make sure that we discuss
that matter a little bit.
I have a few specific
questions to follow up with.
And also about where
were the errors largest?
Why were they there?
What other issues would
you like to highlight?
- Yeah, I'll dive in.
As '16 happens, way off.
Everybody tries to figure it out
because it was so consequentially off.
We just like didn't know the
campaign we should be running.
And so there was one effort
which was sort of public-facing,
which sort of came, which
like everybody knows about it
because it's public-facing.
And there was a lot more
research being done,
but not public-facing.
Which led me to really
understand just how ridiculous
and impossible this problem is.
Because even when you get
down to college, non-college,
it is easy to see that the
Ward Owens mentioned it
and I'm not the academic saying it,
but it's all about
differential response bias.
That some people are more or
less likely to take a survey.
- Actually, I think I did just say it.
That's what I was trying to say.
- I like the jargon.
But anyway, the point is that even you do
college, non-college, turns out if you are
college in a college neighborhood,
you are different than college
in a non-college neighborhood.
And vice versa, if you're non-college.
If you're non-college
and you do manual work,
you're way different than
if you're non-college
and you are a physician's assistant.
And so by thinking that
something as broad as non-college
is a sufficient proxy for the division
is sort of missing that the response bias
isn't because you got a
college degree or not,
it's all these other things
that add up to something else.
And when you think about how it's been,
especially because of
the low response rates,
how expensive it is to do a poll
unless you do these online panels,
like the cost correcting for these things
and the actual collection of the data,
versus fixing it at the
backend is enormous.
So no one pays that price.
Means spending a lot more phone
calls, like a lot of stuff
that makes these polls too
expensive to start doin' that.
And so it's like kind of
just one of these things
where you just have to
accept that you are stuck
with a magnifying glass in a world
that you need a microscope
to see what's going on.
And you're just not gonna know.
You're not gonna know
down to three, four points
what's actually happening
because we don't have a tool
that does that anymore.
- Great, thank you, thank you Mike.
So we have a buncha questions.
I'm gonna try and get to as
many of them as possible.
And we have about 15 or so minutes.
So I would like you, just
sort of keep that in mind
that I'm gonna try and get
through a buncha questions.
And I'd also like as many
perspectives on each question,
if there is a different perspective.
So, okay, keep that in mind.
Okay, so here's some questions.
Let's see, to what extent do
you think the surge in turnout
in this election is going to
affect future rounds of voting?
How persistent will this
increase in turnout be?
Okay, Alex, Lynn says not very.
Okay, Alex, please.
- Well, all I have to
contribute on this topic
is that we know that when you turn out
to vote in one election, you become,
as a causal consequence of voting,
more likely to vote in
subsequent elections.
We know this because of experiments
like Professor Gerber does,
where you induce people to
turnout at random in one group
but not another, and then this
persists for like 20 years.
We know this from people who are just 18,
or just not 18 in one election,
so they were ineligible.
People who were eligible to
vote in the first election
are way more likely to vote
in subsequent elections.
So, we just got a huge treatment
of a whole buncha people
turning out to vote for the first time.
Or a large number of people
turning out to vote first time.
I think that that will
have habit-forming effects.
So, Lynn's thumbs down notwithstanding,
I think that there is some good reason
to think that it will persist.
- We'll actually see some
local elections soon.
And we'll see some things to see
if there's anything like that.
Mike, please and then
if Josh has something.
I can barely see you Josh
because of the questions.
Actually if you can lean
right and then raise your hand
that would be great, thank you.
- So this is like particularly shocking
for Alan and Josh given the role I play
with the Analyst Institute
and all the things like
Get Out the Vote and that,
is that what we saw was ecological.
I mean people voted this time around
because people were voting,
because like I said it was the Superbowl.
Because people who were marginal voters
saw other people like them
thinking this was an
important thing to do.
It was happening everywhere,
even where there were,
and like I said before about
campaign tactics don't matter.
You go to a place in the middle of Utah,
where there's like nothing on the ballot
and people are voting at
a higher rate this year.
It had nothing to do,
it had very little to do
with the campaigning, it
had to do with the fact that
POT voting was enormously
socially salient this time around.
And when you take that
social salience out,
when you take out the fact that you had
Trump making politics the national sport,
and you had the clearest decision ever
before American voters, four
more years of that or not,
yeah, you're gonna get insane turnout.
And that's what we got.
- Okay.
- May I have another-
- Yes, Josh, please, please.
- So I think Alex does a
really good job summarizing
what we know from past elections,
past social science evidence,
that voting is habit forming.
But I think one interesting wrinkle
beyond what Mike was sayin'
about four years of Trump,
what Lynn was holding up about COVID.
I think another
interesting wrinkle is just
half of Americans or so,
who voted in this election,
don't trust the system,
they don't trust the election results.
And if you are a person
who voted this time around,
as a kind of marginal voter
who was mobilized by Donald Trump,
and then you feel your voice wasn't heard,
you don't have trust in the system,
you don't have faith in the system,
you might not turn out and
vote the next time around.
The kind of habit
formation might not kick in
if you don't believe that your
vote wasn't valid to cast.
So I think we just kinda
need to wait to see
whether or not 2020 was some special year
to which the voting is
habit forming literature
just doesn't speak to you.
- Great, thank you Josh.
So there's a question related
to that that I'll read.
Do you think turnout
in the Georgia runoffs
will be depressed on GOP side
because Trump isn't on the ballot
and he's pressing the fraud narrative
making base voters think why
bother since it's rigged?
Any thoughts about that.
- I will say I don't think it will help
Republicans in Georgia to be
making those kind of claims.
Whether it's a large decrease
or a small decrease, I don't know.
But I would guess it's probably
not helpful to their side.
- Other thoughts?
- I think other institutional features
to what's going on with
the pandemic in January.
I actually don't know how they're
going to execute this election.
Will everybody get a mail ballot?
I don't know what the
provisions are there.
But all those things are
gonna effect turnout as well.
- Mike, do you have
anything you wanna add?
- If I can get to sorta
continue to be contrarian
on all this.
I don't think it's about
the social trust part
in going to vote.
I think in this moment with Trump
and the division over sort of
what kind of America you live in.
This is not about like civics,
it's about identity affirmation.
It's like going because
your team is at stake.
And so, I think, we've
literally been polling
every night since the election.
See the same thing that
you're talking about.
But it doesn't play in the
logic you're talking about.
They still wanna go out and
affirm the America they want.
- Alex do you have anything to add? Okay.
So one other aspect of the Georgia runoff
is that it's taking place,
I would think by the time,
I think it's December 15th
when people can start,
start voting if I remember correctly.
By that time it's quite likely
that the election will more clearly,
even more clearly resolved.
In academic political science
some folks are enamored
with balancing arguments
which say that voters,
or at least some, remember
as you've all said,
elections are decided by
a small number of voters
going D versus R, R versus D.
Some of those voters
actually prefer policies
kind of toward the center.
In which case, they sometimes
vote for divided government.
Do you think there's anything
to that argument in general?
And do you think it will
play out at all in Georgia?
- I wake up every day thinking about this.
I do, because so much
hangs in the balance.
- That was part of why I was interested
if you were still polling.
Like are people-
- Yes, yeah.
- [Alan] It sounds like
Mike is also polling.
- Yeah.
- We actually talked about tryin'
to add a question about balancing.
We ultimately decided not to.
But the political scientist
in me wants to say,
that's not happening in a way
that is significant enough
for us to be concerned about.
But the realist in me, who
is not a political scientist,
wakes up in the morning
and says, "Come on,
this has gotta be playin' a role
for some of these people on the margin."
And now, whether those people turn out.
Like this is all very complicated.
You're gonna turn out
because you care a lot
about your party and your ideas
and what Michael just said,
the world you wanna live in.
If you're someone who's
not that committed to party
and you might switch over
to vote for the other party
to give some balance,
maybe you're not motivated
to even turn out in this special election,
on a day that you don't even
know when it's happening,
and et cetera, et cetera.
So, I don't know.
- Mike.
- Yeah I, probably that's right.
That turnout's gonna be lower.
It's like anti-climax in a
lotta, even though we understand
it has greater political
significance for people in Georgia,
it's kind of an anti-climax.
And I don't know whether, which,
I mean it's so close you don't know.
It's crazy to say you know plus or minus,
I just said you don't
know plus or minus two.
And so I've no idea.
But stay in that range.
- Lynn, can I ask you a question,
on this, kind of this
swing voter question.
Swing voters, there's a
very small number of them.
Do we know anything about
their political knowledge?
How many of them even know
who controls the Senate?
That seems like a prerequisite
in order to have this
balancing take place.
Are they aware-
- [Lynn] Yeah, no, that-
- The Senate depends on this Georgia race.
- That's super interesting
and obviously critical
piece of information if
you're gonna try to balance.
And it is true, like
what you're saying is.
People without a party identification,
people who don't know who
they're gonna vote for
until the very end of
an election, on average,
I'm not saying everybody
who fits into this category,
but on average, these people
know less about politics.
They maybe don't know
who controls the Senate.
They don't know how many people
are on the Supreme Court,
et cetera, et cetera.
And if you just think
about that for two seconds
it makes sense.
If you were someone who
was invested in politics,
you probably would lean
toward one party or the other,
especially when nudged twice.
Maybe not the first time,
but eventually you'd say,
"Okay, like yeah, I'm one or the other."
So, I always says these people have
a dictionary for politics
that is just a little bit off.
It doesn't translate very well for them,
the way it does for people
who are more engaged.
- There's a "Saturday Night Live" sketch
about the independent voters
and the questions they demand
that the candidates answer.
And I think the questions
are, who's running,
is the first of the questions.
Okay, so let's see.
Okay, this is, just I'm gonna start
going through these relatively rapidly.
How long do you think it's going to take
for the country to get
rid of the hate legacy
of the Trump years?
Again, it's a non-partisan panel.
I'm just reading the questions.
But I think that you
know, that's a question.
So what are the views?
Do you think Trump is leaving a-
- It depends on elites.
- Political behavior, and
what does it depend on?
That's the question.
- My answer is it depends on elites.
It depends on candidates and
what they choose to talk about
and raise to a level of
importance for voters.
- So I would be strenuously
more pessimistic.
Because there may have been a moment
when elites could do that,
when the McCain could say
he's a Christian, but Trump
has demonstrated a path
to winning Republican
primaries that notice
that the majority of Republican
voters do not want that.
That you win Republican
primaries by not being that.
So there's like no room for Republican,
that kind of Republican elite right now,
because that's what we're stuck with.
And that's what's gonna
be the boundary for them.
They're not gonna do that.
- Okay, next question.
I've seen some exit polls
that believe swing voters
tend to view Republicans as
more focused on the economy
and Democrats more
focused on social issues.
Is this something
Democrats should address?
- Okay, basically my answer to anything,
the question that begins
with the word exit poll
is I wanna answer the question,
because they're just like crazy wrong.
And yet two exit polls at this time,
one said that Trump won white
college women by one point
and that Biden won them by 20.
And exits the last time around,
said seniors were 16% of the vote,
and it's just like all crazy wrong.
Like crazy, demonstrably wrong.
- Okay, so friendly
amendment to the question.
I think it is,
some people think that swing voters,
or some people are concerned
that as a political matter
Republicans are being given the brand
of being concerned about the economy,
whereas Democrats are
being given the brand
as being concerned about social issues.
Is this something the
Democrats should address,
or what do you think of that framing
and is this something?
Again I'm trying to frame the question.
- I think that these kinds of shortcuts
they happen all the time.
And it's natural for
people to want to do them.
This is the party of this and
this is the party of that.
But if the person who asked the question
is really concerned about the economy,
all I would say is like,
I just showed you a graph
of the actual output of
the nation's economy.
People get it.
Like when the economy is growing,
they reelect the incumbent.
So if that's what you're worried about,
that Republicans are always gonna win
because people always want a good economy,
that is not what's happening.
- Okay.
Do the panelists agree
with Westwood, et al
that the forecasts along with,
that the polling forecasts
disproportionately depress
Democratic turnout,
eg. FiveThirtyEight
creating its own weather?
- No.
- Do we think polling
had any material effect on voter behavior?
- No, not in terms of turnout.
I could believe in '16 some
people voted third party
because they didn't like
Clinton or Trump, or either way.
Again, they thought they knew the outcome.
But actually the difference between
voting for or against someone
is like an opinion inside your head.
Going out to vote's a behavior
and you're doing it for
lotsa other reasons.
- Other thoughts? Okay.
What caused the-
- The one with Solomon
Messing, where they randomized.
They randomized whether
election is being described
as a win probability or
like the vote margin.
And people get these two
things very much confused.
So they have a survey
outcome that suggests
that people are less
worried about the election
when they see it as a win probability.
I found that survey experiment
part of it quite compelling.
- Actually, you asked the
question better than I did.
I didn't understand that
part of the question.
Thank you, thank you very much, Alex.
Okay, what caused the high voter turnout
with both Democrats and
Republicans in this election?
What do you think the key factors were?
Or a key factor?
- Really key factor was that
the future of the world was at stake.
And everybody had to listen to politics
every day for four years.
So, right, I mean, that's
different from the last 250 years.
- I'd say the proximity
of the 2016 outcome.
Just how razor, razor close it was.
And then, how surprising
it was to a lot of people.
And then, the ease with
which a lotta people
were able to vote this time
because of vote by mail.
And the constant, constant,
constant commentary
about filling out your ballot.
I mean it was just impossible
not to be hit with.
All those things probably contributed.
- If polls under sample Trump supporters
is an inference from that
that Trump's approval rating
has been underestimated all along as well?
- Sure.
- I don't know that it's clear
that we're under sampling
Trump voters by the way.
But yes, the point is well taken that-
- Like half an hour ago.
We only have one minute left.
- [Lynn] Oh sorry.
- No I'm just kidding.
Mike, is there anything you'd like
to say in response to that?
- The one thing that never
comes up in these conversations
that's really important
is that the polling
is only trying to get what,
like some sense of America thinks.
But that's not always
identical to the people
who show up for the election.
And they're not really the same thing.
So that probably if you
could do a census of America,
Trump's approval would be really horrible.
And a census of America and the election,
there's a lotta room in between.
- Great, okay.
We're coming very close to
the end of our time together.
Each of you if you could,
do you have one more thought
you'd like to share with
us before we depart?
- Analysis coming out.
There's like more data
collected, more results come in.
And I think, stay tuned
to really learn more
about the 2020 election process.
Everything we're saying now,
everything you're hearing
in the media, it's preliminary,
and you really need to wait and be patient
for all the results to come in.
- Okay, I'll-
- Go ahead.
- I saw a lotta a questions
in the Q&A about the Texas
and the Latino vote down there.
And I'll just share one
little piece of analysis
I looked at yesterday.
We were using our data
collection, because we have
almost 500,000 interviews,
we have a lot of interviews
with people from very
different national origins.
So Hispanic ethnicity with
So we were looking at
Mexican national origins
to Mexican Americans,
in Texas you can see that
big shift toward Trump.
But then we said, well
those counties are small
and they're unusual in their size.
Texas has a lotta counties,
those border counties are small counties,
almost all Hispanic population.
What about the Mexican
Americans in Louisiana
and Mississippi and other
conservative states,
who don't make up their own county,
so we're not seeing the county shift.
And so we just looked and they were also
heavily Trump, 59% Trump.
And so, one thing to remember
when you think about counties
is those are sort of arbitrary
drawn geographic units.
They're not the same in every state.
And so that might not be about
border counties in Texas,
it might be about Mexican Americans
in conservative-leaning states.
And in Texas they happen to make up
their own geographic unit.
- Mike?
- I would just say like
what Josh said, but also,
not only wait until at
least February, March
to have a prayer of
understanding what's going on,
what the kinda questions you wanna,
if someone tells you
the answer to a question
you actually care about,
they're telling you
what they thought before the election
and found some data point that
someone threw out somewhere
to validate it.
And that's all and you
just gotta roll with it.
- Great, and one last question,
I'd just like to ask this of folks.
Is there an article, a website, a book,
something that you have read recently,
or some source of
information that you go to,
to learn something about politics
that you would share with the audience?
'Cause anyone who's made
it all the way through
to the end of an hour and 15 minute panel,
they might wanna learn some more.
So what would you recommend?
- I just got Edward Tufte's new book.
He's a political science
professor at Yale, right?
So like it counts.
Really good.
- It sure does, it sure does.
- Alex didn't get his last observation.
- [Alan] He nodded he didn't have-
- Whatever said, it's
already on the screen.
- He didn't take me up on it.
Other sources of information
that you would recommend
like for more, you know
articles that you've read
that are especially
insightful or interesting?
- Well, I've already pitched
Lynn's book in "Message Matters"
and Alan's book "Get Out the Vote."
But there's a third
source that I'll point you
in all seriousness, I think
Nate Cohn at The Upshot
probably does some of the
best election analysis,
public-facing election analysis.
And his Twitter feed,
I think is a really fantastic resource.
- Great, thank you.
- If you like the day-to-day inside scoop
of what's going on, the Politico Playbook
that is every morning
delivered to your inbox,
but that's really for the
people who wanna deep dive.
- Mike?
- Yeah, I'll just repeat
what I said before.
If you didn't read anything
for the last four years
you'd have had a better idea
of what was gonna happen on November 3rd
than if you'd read what
anybody else had written.
- Sure thing.
Okay, well thank you all.
You're amazing, amazing panelists.
It was wonderful of you to
take time out of your evening
to spend with us and to
give us your insights.
Please visit the ISPS
website, isps@yale.edu
to keep up with ISPS events and research
and look for announcements
of future events.
If you would like, you
could join our mailing list
to receive a monthly newsletter.
See the website for more details.
With that, I thank you all
for spending the time with us this evening
and I hope to see you
at future ISPS events.
Good evening to you all, bye, bye.